hi in this video we are going to talk
about class two MHC antigen presenting
pathway now all the antigen presenting
cells such as dendritic cell macrophage
and the B cell has one thing in common
they present their exogenous pep peptide
on the on top of a class 2 MHC molecule
and we need to look at that what is the
process by which class 2 MHC are
synthesized what are the process by
which exogenous antigens or peptides are
loaded onto the class 2 MHC molecule and
how they are presented on the cell
surface all of these things are going to
be covered in this video so stay tuned
to the end of this video and watch it so
here is a dendritic cell which is an
antigen presenting cell so with its long
process which are dendritic like
processes it samples bacteria or any
other pathogens so whenever it
encounters a bacteria it would engulf
the bacteria and phagocytosed it right
so in that phagocytose sized bacteria
the phagosome would ultimately fuse with
lysosomes present inside the dendritic
cell now the lysosomal content would
ultimately degrade the bacteria and
release the antigens present in these
bacteria so these are the source of the
exogenous antigens or the pathogen
derived antigen meanwhile we have to
understand that inside the nucleus of
the dendritic cell MHC genes are
expressed so it makes the genes are
expressed in a cluster known as H in a
cluster or human leukocyte antigen
cluster so for simplicity imagine there
is a ma see gene which is encoded in
coding the MHC RNA and that would be
transported outside the nucleus and on
the endoplasmic reticulum it would be
translated now it turns out that there
are two chains of MHC class 2 molecule
alpha and beta and both are transcribed
from different gene segments which lead
to assembly of these two component of
MHC molecules and this assembly process
takes place in the endoplasmic reticulum
now in the endoplasmic reticulum there
are lot and lot of endogenous peptides
which are destined to be loaded onto
class one MHC molecules now how does
these peptides are not loaded onto the
class 2 MHC molecules that's a great
question which bothered scientists for a
while later on it was discovered that
there is a peptide which is blocking the
MHC peptide binding groove or antigen
binding groove this peptide is known as
the invariant chain itself this
invariant chain makes sure that none of
the endogenous antigens are presented on
top of class 2 MHC molecules and this is
very important right and these in this
invariant chain also help the class 2
MHC molecule to be transported from ER
to the golgi body and follow the cell
secretory cells pathway now from the
Golgi body it would travel through the
Golgi Network and ultimately it would be
moving towards the endosome invisible
vesicle so it is very important that we
understand the function of the invariant
chain because if the invariant chain is
not there then there could be
detrimental effect because the self
peptides would be presented on class 2
MHC molecules and there are risk of
autoimmune development and there would
be a breach in the tolerance system
however invariant chain serves its
purpose and prevents any kind of
endogenous antigen to be presented on a
plasti MHC also it helps in the
transport which is pretty much
established right now experiments have
shown in a case where these invariant
chain genes are mutated in that case the
class 2 MHC molecules are retained in
the ER they are never displayed on the
cell surface that means it also helps in
the intracellular transport of the MHC
class 2 molecules ok so let's look at
what happens when the MHC class 2
molecule reached the endosome remember
in this endosome there was
Tyrael peptides right which were there
by which were generated there by the
lysosomal degradation of the bacteria
but meanwhile there is a huge shift in
the pH and as a result a portion of
these invariant chain is actually
degraded now but there is a clip peptide
which is still blocking the peptide
binding groove another non-classical MHC
molecule known as HL ADM HL a DM helps
to remove this clip peptide such that
the MHC is groove peptide binding groove
is now open and exogenous antigens can
be loaded onto the class 2 MHC molecule
now HLA DM is not normally expressed on
the cell surface but it is mostly found
in the phagosome or mostly found in the
endosomal vesicles or in decimal
compartments and we understand the role
of HLA DM now since HLA DM has freed the
peptide binding groove now all the
antigens which are derived from the
bacteria that means the exogenous
antigens can now be loaded onto the
peptide binding groove of class 2 MHC
molecules after that class 2 MHC
molecules would be transported to the
cell surface and it would fuse to the
cell membrane and would be finally
displayed onto the dendritic cell
membrane now this class to bind antigen
bound antigens would be ultimately
displayed to the cd4 positive helper T
cells in fact this antigen presentation
would give the cd4 positive helper cell
a signal that it needs to recognize it
and get need to get activated so that is
how it makes the bound peptide displays
work and this is now MHC bound peptide
helps the cd4 positive T cells to get
activated so I hope you get a broad
picture of how MHC class 2 molecules are
displaced this plane on the cell surface
so I hope you enjoyed this video if you
liked this video give a thumbs up don't
forget to Like share and subscribe thank
you